My name is Josh Wiseman, I've been at Facebook for two years now.
Photos is my favorite application on the site.
It's, by far, the most popular application.
We didn't necessarily expect it be as huge as it was.
But as soon as we launched it...
...and we started to see that growth curve, it was pretty clear that...
...we were soon gonna overtake everyone as far as photo sharing on the Internet.
We're receiving almost 2,000 photo uploads per second.
We get 40 million photos uploaded every single day.
So, that's well over a billion a month.
Storing 40 billion files is a pretty daunting task.
As with any of these kinds of systems, they are simple in very small scale.
They get infinitely complex in large scale.
I get the most satisfaction just from seeing how much my friends and family have started to use it.
We're allowing people to share this information...
...and these experiences that they couldn't share before,...
...you know, photos of their friends having fun, taking them with like a cellphone camera...
That's something that really, there was no great way to do it before Facebook.
There's a huge amount of room for engineers to come in and...
...not just help out on some of these projects, but start these projects...
...and brainstorm new ones, and I think Photos is a really good example.
It was started by one person a few years ago and...
...a few of us have dabbled in it since then.
With a team of three or four people which sounds...
...pretty small by industry standards, we could accomplish so much more with Facebook Photos.
There's just much more room for the engineering department to grow.